where does a movie begin for you
i think for me our movie really begins
uh with an idea
or the story the key story element or
or the what if like this is kind of like
a fall
um and sometimes like uh low
will bring you know we'll have an idea
or have a dream
uh and say oh this is really great and
you're like i always jot it down
like i jot down her ideas and and her
dreams and my dreams
when i have an idea or a thought i wake
up from or if i'm daydreaming and
and like oh you know so i kind of try to
write all those little thoughts down
and then eventually what i find happens
is there's some
of those ones that get written down
there's one that kind of keeps chirping
keep like hey and like it like more
ideas
come to it and at a certain point it
reaches critical mass i mean usually
when i have like
10 or 12 pages of ideas relating to a
particular story it kind of reaches the
critical mass where i start going okay
now we're going to figure out the you
know what this is is a real
script you know all these ideas are
great and then figuring out what
coalesces into the script
and then it kind of evolves like i work
with low like
ever you know when i finish the first
draft is very useful because she usually
gets fresh eyes on it at that point
so it's great to get like a fresh
perspective and then the story grows and
then of course
as you are inspired by locations or
or real things you experience and
oftentimes when you
as it progresses like when you start
casting
like an actor can be a huge like
influence in terms of
like oh this person is like changes that
character this could make the movie turn
into this
so all those things kind of and it just
kind of grows so it's fun
it's my probably my favorite part is
like
developing the story and once that
happens once that chirping
is so loud then how do you bring it to
life how do you know that it's time to
start casting
that this is like this is something
worth spending time writing a script on
well it's funny it's like sometimes i i
don't know
until after i've written the script i
mean i've written i was giant bin of
scripts
sometimes i'll sometimes i'll finish the
first draft of the script
and and i'll feel like okay well that's
good for now i finished this first draft
and there it is and i read it go
okay this is interesting but not right
now and it'll go in the bin
uh so sometimes like just in the process
of writing the first draft
but then if i finish the first draft and
lo looks at it and i look at it and go
hmm
there's something here then it might
lead to the second draft the third draft
the fourth draft
at a certain point the story gets to a
point where you're like yes
this this story's here it's like this is
a
really really good story and we should
we should really make it and at that
point it kind of like then it kind of
moves into the pre-production phase or
like or the
phase of like well how can we actually
make it happen you know
so writing a script is almost like a
safety valve in some sense because
if you see that first draft and you're
like uh
okay i did it i'm not like totally wild
about it imagine you spend
two three years trying to you know get
it made raise money get distribution all
that
well that's what it really boils down to
because it's so hard
as an indie filmmaker to make a movie it
has to be one that you kind of like
are insane to make because the journey
is gonna be so
difficult so it has to be an idea that
can really stand that test of time
that you can live with it for that time
to not only make it but then
you gotta do the festival circuit then
you gotta get the distributor and then
once the distributor takes it you got to
work on the marketing of it to help the
distributor out so people know the movie
exists
so it's a very long process it usually
ends up being a three to five year
process
when you go through the whole cycle so
it better it needs to be an idea that
you feel
really really really strongly about um
it's interesting because if i was in a
position probably to snap my fingers
a lot of these other scripting ideas
that i i probably would love to see into
fruition if i knew it could be a shorter
cycle
and i think they could actually be
really really good stories it'd be
entertaining and people would enjoy
but the trick is because there's always
so much you can do
you kind of have to pick the one that
kind of leaps to the top like
me you know your mother you know you've
got you got a new me and that's kind of
you know it seems like there's always
one which
will float to the top like that and also
it's realistically it's
it's money and budget it's like i have
ideas all the time
i can't make into uh
i feature film right now because it's
too much money i can't raise it
uh you go through the process of trying
to shop it to people and get a producer
involved and you go through that process
but you know that on our own we can't do
it it would need someone else
involved which we'd love to do and we
have several of those that we
you know hope hopefully one day will
happen but that's kind of on a different
track than the ones that you do is just
a straight up indie
filmmaker because that's a little bit
more out of control because your
dependent
excuse me on some different people
saying yes so it's like you you know
it's like that's not completely unfair
control was the ones that you know that
no matter what you can do if you set
your mind to it
those kind of move to the top as well
because nothing can stop you as long as
you decide to do it
you know that's the only thing that
would stop you from doing it is the
decision like yes i'm doing this one
you